le gadget s'amuse parfois le
psychosociologue et ça vous amis il y en
a partout dans votre cuisine dans votre
journal dans votre voiture
le gadget c'est la nouveauté l'objet de
demain que vous achetez justement parce
que c'est nouveau
le nouveau produit une nouvelle manière
de faire fortune nouveau type de pdg
paul loup sulitzer à 25 ans la fureur du
porte-clés c'était lui le stylo géant la
tirelire qui explose c'était encore lui
c'est monsieur gadgets quelque chose qui
a étonné en arrivant ici c'est votre
cadre de vie
vous n'habitez pas à dire
moderne appartement design n'est pas de
gadgets
ici pas du tout pourquoi je moi
personnellement je ne suis pas je n'aime
pas tellement les gadgets j'en ai vu
tellement j'ai vécu au milieu dans mes
bureaux il y avait été vraiment j'ai
vécu j'étais environné de toutes sortes
de gadgets gens recevaient tous les
jours par la poste j'ai plus envie de me
retrouver dans le même cadre où j'ai
passé 50 ans d'existence petit denman
bon quand on se comprend on va atteindre
fonction hyper fonctionnalités ou sortes
de maladies de la fonctionnalité dans
notre société
oui à la fonctionne consiste à faire des
alternateurs des paquebots la fonction
dit dans 6t sert peut-être des
télévisions etc
et puis il ya la fonction existe à
découper le pamplemousse qui consiste à
découper les oeufs à la coque qui
consiste à éviter que les huer la coop
contiennent de l'air quand on les fait
cuire et qu'ils éclatent par conséquent
il me semble ce que serait le gadget
et puis il faut le dire ne procure ce
délicieux moment de plaisir
elle ne montrait un truc que tu connais
pas ça cale auparavant
le chant d'oiseau dans une boîte appuyé
là dessus car hellman quelle est votre
définition à vous du cas de jette
je crois que le beau gadget beaucoup de
choses il faut quand même d'essayer de
réfléchir pour mettre un peu d'ordre
dans cette notion lalalalalalalalalalala
je crois qu'il ya en allant du plus
immédiate au plus fou il ya plusieurs
catégories
la première celle qui me vient la
première listed à l'esprit c'est l'objet
que les gens la grande masse des gens
considèrent comme un gadget
quand on est dans un grand magasin par
exemple nous allons dans le rayon de
neige ustensiles de cuisine et il ya un
rayon gadget
ce sont des objets qui servent à la
ménagère voulait rendre sandra les plus
aisés tire-bouchon déroulé d'une
conception absolument nouvelle
il permet soin d'enfoncer le bouchon
soit 2 le perforer afin de faciliter le
passage du liquide
bon ça c'est le propre c'est le stade le
plus immédiat plus le plus inférieur
c'est jeudi entre guillemets mais sans
notion péjorative
ensuite il y a le gadget qui est déjà un
peu plus inutiles qui est toujours utile
mais dans lequel on a introduit une
notion d'humour fer à repasser à
roulettes se faire se déplace plus
rapidement qu'un fer ordinaire ce qui
fait gagner un temps précieux à la
ménagère
la chose qui m'intéresse le plus
personnellement c'est le stade final
c'est à dire quand l'objet ne sert plus
à rien qu'à rêver ou a fait rire balança
ballon maman ne soyez plus négligente
contrôler les poids des ballons avec
lesquels jouent vos enfants il en rade
leur santé je suis de formation
surréaliste et je crois que
c'est ce qui m'intéresse dans l'objet de
telles que vous le nommez gadget mais
qui n'est plus gadget enfin un peu le
foot ou le gadget c'est l'auberge
espagnole née en pleine seconde il y a
dix ans le mot gadgets n'existait pas le
gadget serait-il innovations des années
60 une création spécifique de notre
temps pour moi je pense que par exemple
l'apparition de la fourchette si le mot
gadgets avait existé à cette époque là
on aurait sûrement aimé ça un gadget ça
paraissait pas du tout une chose
utilitaires les gens avaient toujours
mangé avec leurs toits dans avec une
cuillère la soupe qu'ils avaient dans
leurs écuelles ils ont dû trouver ton
extrêmement bizarre un jour qu'une
classe disent privilégier à cette époque
là se servent de ce pesticide ans il est
comme ça avec deux pointes au bout pour
nous pour manger un peuple est
proprement
et puis depuis on a eu des quantités
thorn fourchette parisienne une des
dents et remplacée par une baguette de
bois ce qui permet de manger soit comme
en europe soit à la façon extrême
orientale fourchette de sûreté par son
absence de pointe
elle est particulièrement recommandée
aux enfants fourchette à spaghetti
rapidité et élégance sont obtenus avec
ce véritable petit vilebrequin de table
peut servir également pour la choucroute
je crois qu'inconsciemment ça c'est une
hypothèse que je vous envoie comme ça
j'ai l'impression que les gens se
défendent par l'humour de cette
agression
il a fait c'est comme ça que je me sens
personnellement l'agression des objets
rien tron en quand on rentre dans une
boutique on est littéralement assaillis
par tous ces objets qui doit vous rendre
la vie plus facile et finalement nous
vous la rendre plus facile parce que si
votre moulin électrique tombe en panne
eh bien vous ne devez pas vous avant
votre café le matin on ramasse miettes
par exemple c'est un gadget bon bah
quand la bonne femme en deux deux coups
de cuillère à pot la ramasse et 2 mm il
fallait qu'elle met une heure avant a
ramassé que grâce à ça elle peut
s'occuper de ces gosses pour moi c'est
pas con pour moi c'est utile est-ce que
les quatre jets qui le sont proposés
actuellement
sans utiliser m'en charger de rêve pour
vous intéresser
oui oui et des gadgets que vous adoptez
qui font maintenant partie de notre
univers
oui en tant qu objet insolite comme we
content quand l'objet d'un solide par
exemple envoyer ce cadre est magnifique
pavé au plat
[Musique]